fans of the expanded universe know that
Luke was previously tempted by the dark
side going so far as to become The
Apprentice to the emperor himself the
story line occurred in one of the first
expanded universe Stories the apply
named dark Empire this 1991 comic book
from Darkhorse Comics takes place just a
handful of years after Return of the
Jedi and it sees the emperor return from
his presumed death at the end of that
film with the explanation being that he
transferred his Consciousness to a
cloned body at the moment of his death
somehow Palpatine returned Luke sh to
see him alive agrees to become his
Apprentice with his plan being to bring
down the resurgent Empire from the
inside but the dark side corrupts Luke
and he loses sight of his goal it takes
a lightsaber fight against Leia for him
to snap out of it and at that point he's
finally able to defeat Palpatine dark
Luke would have been cool to see on the
big screen but the window for this story
closed long ago